today we've got a very SPECIAL day
I'm wearing aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa (what could it possibly be felix?)
wireless VR headset (totally couldn't have guessed that)
So I'm
READY!!!1!
I can jump around WHEREVER I want
Let's see... what wireless VR has to offer the future (what)
LET'S GO
OH, M A N
this is
SO C00l
da graphics are so REEL
*massacres ppl*
*gets on ground and sexually spreads legs*
YEAH
take
THIS (felix says as his legs are casually spread)
*more murdering*
Take this you stupid soldiers!!1!
this is the future, guys  ╮(✿⊙▽⊙)╭
I'm wireless! ??????
B)
I can do whatever I want!
this is so cool!
oh man!
i feel like theres an open world out there for me ready to explore!!!!1!
its like a whole new world out there (cue aladdin)
i feel so free! (Haru=Felix EXPOSED)
ah
the graphics smell amazing in this game! *wot*
ah, dis is so c00l
its almost like i'm outside!
holy SHIT this looks so real
oh ma gawd
It's like just like im in a game
*felix kicks pop can*
WHAT WOZ THAT
the graphics are SOOOO good in this game!
*felix casually runs into chair*
holy shit, this is so c00l (you've said it 7 times felix)
I'm in the matrix, guys! (your in gta stupid)
slight asthma
I HEARD SOMETHING they said *gay*
*people recording*
its must be something.... A GLITCH! (what?)
*cute waving*
WHERE AM I (on earth) (whatever touches the light is yours simba)
I'm gonna go... IM GOING FOR IT! (dat boi is gonna frogger)
*realistic car crash*
where am I? (again?)
oh its an underwater level coming up guys! holy shit
*sexy stumble*
owh
whut was that?!?1!
..a trap?
WHOT WOZ THAT?!!?!?!
ENEMIES?!!?!?!?!?!
*rolling along*
*pant*
HALP
PLeAsE
*dying*
the civilians... are ignoring me!
which reality am i in? (none)
I don't know where I am... i want to make it to safety
*pewdiepie humps wall*
oh god
it's a big wall here!
*sensual crawling*
*grunting*
NO PROBLEM ;)
*pewds falls along with his dignity*
*So wants to be like Nathen Drake*
wAAHHH!!
*music changes* hm
pewds starts mating ritual
*music changes* again
fuck yeah this is cool!
this is ALMOST LIKE SKATE-BOARDING IN REAL LIFE! *face palm*
AM I TONY HAWK RIGHT NOW GUYS *rly*
uh uh uh (pewds stop)
hows it going guys
we got some scrub-uh-skateboarders over here (lol)
can i skate with u guys?
come on!
lemme skate
damn i got so much speed!
so much power >:)
this is the coolest... ive ever seen (out of 1000+vids?)
a video game!1
holy shit im so fast!!
*rip pewdiepie*
AWH
*zombie walk*
man
i'm really feeling this ;)
*girly giggle*
I'm in another game!!1!
oh my god
*close-up*
there's a car-level coming up!
how ya ladies doin? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
announcer guy: I just dont know man!
announcer guy: i just dont know chump!¯\_(ツ)_/¯
announcer guy: i just dont know man
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
lemme see it
*pewds scores* OH! *cheering*
This guy thinks "what is life".
what is this place?..
*pewds falls (again)* *things fall off of pewds*
*camera guy laughs*
where am I? *pewds repeats*
so many people in this pla--
*crash*
(pewds continues crashing for the next 30 seconds)
*girl singing while poods dances*
girl: YAYAHAAAA
girl: you cant just stay there
pewds: I CAN BREAKDANCE
girl: woowoowoo
*girl continues singing as she backs away*
up here
i'm bout to check it out!
dude: wtf
where am I?
halp
wheres the pork in this dam (??)
OH MA GAWD
hunter.. what is this? (i have no idea what he's saying at this point)
i dont know where to go!
what is happening...?
wot is this?
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
*chukle*             dedede (what)
where can i go *idk*
YEEAHH
*pewds screams really loudly*
WHAT THE FUCK?
AAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
oh
OH (pewds no one likes that noise. it sounds wrong)
WAH!
*CAMERA NOISE*
ah!
EUUUUUUUHHHHHHHH
WHAT THE
???
wow
that feels like a real rollercoaster
-_-
*rides bull and fails*
tries again and fails again
*face palm*
*how*
*sexy walk*
but this was uploaded on the 29th
*walks into sea without noticing he was walking into the sea maybe he became a mermaid idk*
*becomes mermaid and meets sebastian the crab*
end